during spring 2018 tens of thousands of
teachers walked out of their schools
these walk outs attracted extensive
media attention prompting RJ Martin and
I to examine coverage in five major
newspapers what did we find a mix of
good and bad it's a good national papers
published a total of 59 articles on the
strikes of these 56 had impartial
headlines and leads impressive the bad
the 254 quotes in the 59 stories favored
the strikes by a 5 to 1 margin a ratio
that far exceeded actual public opinion
meanwhile affected families were almost
never quoted worse that coverage did
little to put compensation in context or
to explain how teacher salary stack up
against median household income in their
state stories also rarely noted the cost
of generous health care and pension
plans and that's a problem because these
benefits are a big part of any serious
conversation about teacher pay
newspapers can do better and with more
strikes looming they'll have plenty of
chances how do you think media covered
the teacher strikes let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI